Alright Michael, you got the answer?
>> Yea, I'm ready to try and figure it out.
>> Alright let's go. Let's try the first one.
>> I feel like the first one's going to go rather well. So we
need a pair of strategies so that no player is. Motivated to switch.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And you told us they were pure strategies, so we actually have a nice
algorithm for doing this, which is we could
just check one of them with the definition.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, but in the case of prisoner's dilemma, I think
a natural place to start would be that minus 6, minus 6.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So let's say that A chooses the second row and B
chooses the second column, let's see if that's a Nash Equilibrium. So
both players need to be happy. So if, would A be happier
switching? If A switched, it would be getting minus 9, which is worse.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So A is happy, where A is. And if B
switches, B would be getting minus 9, so boom, Nash Equilibrium.
>> Done.
>> Now I didn't verify that other
ones weren't a Nash Equilibrium, but you didn't
say. Find all of the Nash Equilibrium. You just
said find, well you did say find the.
So you kind of implied that there's just one.
>> Right. But actually that's true, but you don't have to check this because
we already went through an exercise where we, where we knew the answer was minus
6, minus 6. And the way we did that was we noticed that for A defecting the
second row is always better than this. Right? And then in particular this
row strictly dominates this row.
>> Right.
>> Which implies that if I picked anything on this
row I would rather move to the other row. And
you can see it. Minus 1 0 is better. Minus
9, minus 6 is better. That's what it means to
be strictly dominated. So, I'd never pick this row anyway.
And this same argument for B for this column. So,
you'll notice that by getting rid of the things that
are strictly dominated, the only thing we're left with is this.
And, it turns out, in fact, to be a Nash Equilibrium. So, this is correct.
>> So, you just told me how to do my job, which makes me little sad.
>> Well, in this instance.
>> Because I already had the answer to this. But maybe, maybe
you were signalling to me how I might attack this next problem. Maybe.
>> Maybe.
>> So, A is choosing a row and gets the first number.
So, is there a row, that, were they dominates all the other rows?
It doesn't seem that way.
>> Mh-hm
>> But maybe, maybe, oh I could start with B, maybe B, there's a
column that dominates all the other columns.
But no, it looks like it's totally symmetrical.
>> Yep, so strictly dominated doesn't necessarily
help here, and by necessarily I mean doesn't.
>> So that was kind of mean. Thank you.
>> All right, so oh, but we have something else we could do.
>> Yes.
>> So, there is a, the largest number that anybody can
get is 6.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And there's a play where both of them can get the 6.
>> Yeah.
>> So there's no way they're going to want
to switch away from that, because everyone's getting there
kind of maximum out of reward. So A
bottom row, B right column, gets us Nash Equilibrium.
>> And that is in fact correct, and you can
see it because from here I would always, it would
always be worse for me, and it would always worse
for me. So, these are in fact the Nash Equilibrium,
for these two problems.
>> Cool. They've seemed easier than I was expecting.
>> Mm-hm.